- So I took that
Pottermore quiz yesterday.
I got sorted in to Slytherin.
- What's wrong with Slytherin?
- [Voiceover] People assume being sorted
in to Slytherin is a bad thing.
- You know, "there's not a single
witch or wizard who went bad
that wasn't in Slytherin."
- A, that's not true,
and B, I'm a Slytherin.
- Really?
- [Voiceover] They consider them selfish,
power hungry, and evil.
- But you're not evil.
- Exactly, I'm not.
- [Voiceover] In truth, there's
a lot more to Slytherins
than just being one of the bad guys.
Slytherins are often perceived
as being power hungry.
- Yeah I'm gonna be out
of the office next week
for a little vacation,
but if someone could
take over in the meantime?
- [Voiceover] And though it's true
they like to be in control,
- I'll do it.
- [Voiceover] It's not always
for reasons you'd expect.
- Alright, now that I'm in charge,
everyone can bring
their dog to the office.
- [Voiceover] It's true Slytherins can get
a little competitive sometimes,
okay very competitive.
And yes, they're not exactly the
easiest people to make friends with.
- Hi, I'm Chantelle, I'm new here.
- Cool, welcome.
- [Voiceover] That doesn't
mean they're horrible people.
They just prefer to have a
small group of tightly knit
friends compared to a large
group of mediocre ones.
- And then I said, "witch please!."
(laughter)
Yes, yes!
- [Voiceover] And if anyone messes
with part of their inner circle...
- Hey, what's up, you're Ravenclaw right?
- [Voiceover] ...that
person better watch out.
If a Slytherin is ever
looking particularly evil,
it's usually for a good reason.
- So I'm sure you're all curious
who the Employee of the Month is?
Zayn was again our top
performer in terms of numbers,
but we're actually gonna give it
to Kenny for his moral fiber.
- [Voiceover] Really though, Dumbledore's
a (bleeped) asshat.
If you've been sorted in to Slytherin,
don't let that get you down.
Remember, it could always be worse.
You could have been a Hufflepuff.
- I found some cookies
if anyone wants, ahhh!
I got surprised by your teeth.